[Music]
all right let's go to joe in orlando
let's get orlando hey man i'm orlando
orlando joe in orlando wouldn't you know
what's up man
hi john thank you for having me on the
show i'm a big fan you got it man i'm a
big fan of you what's up
uh so uh keeping it short i'm 26
married and i'm having troubles with my
in-laws
what kind of troubles
me and my wife have been living with my
in-laws ever since we got married
uh due to
uh going to school going to work and all
that
hold on
back that thing up
um how long you all been married
2015 so gonna be
about eight years in november
and you've been living with them all
this time
yes
i don't even know what you're about to
say and i will tell you yes you probably
have problems with your in-laws
my guess is and i went to a lot of grad
school and i'm a genius
my guess is if you live with your
in-laws for the better part of a decade
in a new young marriage you're probably
gonna have problems with your in-laws
why are you living at home with your
in-laws
so initially it was an agreement
between me and my wife while we finish
school
did you get drugged married real young
we got married in our second year
college
i had just turned 21.
oh my gosh
i know that sounded like a good idea
that was probably even a worse idea so
you at 21
you were how you were junior in college
i guess
uh second year second year sophomore and
what year was she
no sophomore as well we're the same age
oh man
and
is there like an apartment or a back
house or are you just like down the hall
down the hall
oh
gosh
so let me just back up here
sophomores in college
daughter comes home and says i found my
husband i'm going to marry him soon
and we're going to move back into my
my old high school bedroom is that right
no
so
uh when we got married we had moved from
puerto rico here to orlando uh-huh
um
so we had found initially an apartment
just for us okay but then her family
came along and we decided to group into
a larger apartment
her mother-in-law and father-in-law had
some issues
so they split up
we changed to a new apartment where we
are now which is a lot smaller so
the space is very uncomfortable but
tensions between my mother-in-law and
myself
keep growing throughout the years and i
can't find a way of convincing my wife
that it's time to move out
especially now since my mother-in-law
dude covet lost her job so technically
we're paying
for
the majority of expenses
brother
and i i'm not trying to paint that she's
a terrible person no dude you don't have
to you don't have to
i love my mom i love my mother-in-law
i could not live in an apartment with
her for a decade either of them
yeah
and so
you and you can't either
your mother-in-law cannot respect
you
because you still live in her apartment
as the as the
as the man who married her daughter
and this isn't like a
like a gendered thing like a paternal
thing
this is
you promise to take care of my daughter
and still living in my apartment
oh she doesn't want us to leave that's
the issue
i know
it's the it's a catch-22 dance you're in
she can't respect you and she doesn't
want you to leave
and your wife is stuck
dude i don't know i don't say this you
gotta move and i know that you know that
but
there's no amount this is eight years is
a decade there's no amount of gentle
conversations you all may have to help
pay for rent for a season or your
mother-in-law's gotta get a job
there is no easy way out but you've
gotta move and you've gotta move asap
i know that i just don't know how to let
my wife know because every time we bring
the conversation up she just tells me
she can't because she has agreed to help
her mom out then you have to hear that
for what it is
your wife is choosing her mother over
you your wife is saying i don't want to
be married to you anymore i want to be
my mother's i still want to i want to
live at home with my mom
and so you have to
do what
i guess that's what i'm afraid of don't
be afraid of it it's happened
it's not a might it it's an is
but sometimes
my guess is you beat around the bush a
little bit and you say i just really
think it's about time
i think you've got to be bold and you've
got to say
it's time to move out 60 days we're out
of here
you're going on a decade man how old are
you
i'm 26.
what do you do for a living
i just graduated at the end of the
summer and i started a
a job at a software engineering company
okay
how much money do you make
uh right now it's my first year as
intern so 50 000 a year
first year as an intern
like an intern position and then after
the first year if i
if i qualify
like they hire you as an intern for your
first year and then afterwards if you
make the cut you go up to 70.
man that's a
i don't know a lot of 50 000 intern jobs
that's pretty great pretty great pay man
so does your wife work too
uh she works at a walmart okay well
she's still finishing school
are y'all going to grad school or
something what's taking so long
because
uh she's helping pay and we weren't we
didn't qualify for financial aid or
anything we've been paying out of pocket
for college so you're not you're not you
didn't go into a bunch of debt
well i i had that stupid debt before the
marriage my wife says not okay good for
you guys for figuring it out man
yeah um here's what has to happen asap
um let me ask you this you mentioned you
moved from puerto rico
um is there cultural challenges here too
not for me but for her and her family
yes okay is she from puerto rico
no they're from another place they're
from colombia okay uh they struggle a
lot more well i was a struggle there's
just some there's some
uh i want to honor the
cultural differences where you don't
just
the the
a lot of my
a lot of western culture says
suck it up mom you're on your own and
there's other cultures that say no
you're part of our family you're gonna
move in
so at some point you've got a
you're about to lose your marriage
what's about to happen
you're sick of it you're getting sick of
your wife and you're about to implode is
that fair
i already imploded on my mother-in-law
so yeah i'm pretty close on
i'm
like
my temper is getting out of hand
ah hold on hold on you're choosing that
brother
you don't make that choice you got it
okay
don't say it's getting out of hand as
though it's some other thing that's you
making choices
okay if you need to go get a hotel room
because your mother-in-law's yelling at
you or hol or whatever do that be a
person of character
but don't blow up and say it's because
of it it's not you choose that okay take
ownership of your feelings and your
emotions and your thoughts and then take
ownership of your actions
don't let this situation take your
character from you
um
you all have to
let me ask you one more question though
before i start telling you i think you
should do you have your eye on somebody
else
no
no
no
the only people i interact with is my
wife and my best friend who's a guy
other than that
no other social circle okay you've got
to get one by the way
um
this thing is
it's suffocating you and you know that
um yeah the time for the conversation is
is now where you need to take your wife
out to dinner and say we've talked about
this we've thought about this we have to
move out of this apartment
um it could be that you rent a small
house and your mother-in-law lives in
your house under your rules
under
um
y'all's your family values of this young
family y'all have not left y'all are
still children y'all are
weird romantic brother and sister living
in this house you have to get your own
place
with your own values begin creating your
own
here's for me and my house
and your mother-in-law is welcome to
live there
but you can't live in her apartment that
you pay for anymore
okay
and you've got to have a hard
conversation with your wife and if she
says i'm not leaving my mom then you
need to be bold and say
are you choosing to not be married to me
anymore
and you're choosing to live with your
mother instead
you've got to be very clear
very very clear about this
and hopefully she'll say well no i want
both you say awesome i accept both i
understand when i married you
i also married into your
your heart and into your culture and i
married into the idea that we don't put
um our parents in homes they live with
us excellent but they live with us
not us with them
and that sounds like this is semantics
it's a big difference
and then you and your wife need to have
conversations and discussions who are we
gonna be what is our future vision for
this thing what kind of house are we
going to have we have a joyful house a
dancing house a serious house where are
we going to live what kind of town do we
want to be where are we going to be
those are conversations that y'all too
have together
and mother-in-law can come live with you
and by the way mother-in-law has to get
a job
soon
that means you and your wife have to
have a budget here's what it's going to
cost to live here's what's going to cost
to buy food and home all those things
you have to be very serious about
creating a home conversation y'all
should've had eight years ago you didn't
cool period at the end of that sentence
period at the end of that sentence
now what's next now what's next
but yeah joe you got to get out of that
house holy smokes [ __ ] get out of that
house
and i hope your wife wants to be married
to you
bring your mother-in-law along it's in
your house